départ ce n'était pas gagné hein cet
accord entre les deux chambres du
Parlement sur ce projet de loi qui
accélère le développement de nos
énergies renouvelables madame la
ministre c'est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite par l'accord qui a été trouvé
entre député et sénateurs sur ce texte
je crois que la méthode que j'ai mise en
place pour co-construire ce texte et
effectivement prendre en compte tous les
enrichissements les avancées que les
députés les sénateurs ont souhaité
apporter au texte cette méthode elle a
porté ses fruits on a pu montrer qu'on
était capable sur un sujet qui était
historiquement très sensible de dégager
un accord un accord qui est au
rendez-vous de l'histoire parce que il
nous faut produire plus d'énergie plus
d'énergie à bas prix et plus d'énergie
plus d'énergie qui soit bas carbone pour
protéger notre planète c'est ce que
permet ce texte de loi donc oui je salue
cet accord j'espère qu'il sera voté dans
les prochains jours pour que nous nous
mettions maintenant au travail pour
déployer cette loi et faire en sorte que
tous les élus locaux et les instruments
pour le foyer justement cette
indépendance énergétique qu'ils
appellent de leurs vœux et concrètement
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années qu'elles vont être les
conséquences de cette loi en termes de
l'énergie renouvelable c'est d'abord un
gain de temps puisque je prends
l'exemple de l'éolien marin les mesures
que nous prenons vont permettre de
gagner plusieurs années sur les projets
c'est aussi une méthode de planification
qui remet les élus de terrain au centre
du jeu qui leur permet de définir les
zones où ils veulent installer des
énergies renouvelables et lorsqu'ils le
font des zones ou ils ne souhaitent pas
qu'il y ait d'énergie renouvelable et
puis ce sont des engagements
inaccélération notamment pour mettre des
panneaux
photovoltaïques là où nous avons déjà
artificialisé les sols ou là où les sols
sont dégradés le long des routes sur le
littoral dans des anciennes sur des
anciennes décharges sur les parkings sur
les toitures donc c'est vraiment une
accélération de nos capacités à produire
de l'électricité alors il y a un autre
texte sur l'énergie qui a été adopté
cette semaine par le Sénat c'est le
projet de loi qui accélère la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires les sénateurs de droite l'ont
adopté ma vie avec une modification
quand même substantielle ils ont
supprimé l'objectif de limiter en 2035 à
50 % la part du nucléaire de notre mix
énergétique compte tenu de cette
modification et ce qu'il peut y avoir un
accord entre sénateur et député et
majorité présidentielle sur ce texte
nucléaire écoutez je crois que nous ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que le débat
public soit respecté et aujourd'hui se
déroule un débat public avec les
Françaises et les Français qui sont
invités à formuler leurs questions leurs
inquiétudes à faire des propositions sur
l'utilisation de l'énergie nucléaire sur
notre territoire ce débat il doit être
entendu et les sénateurs et les députés
toivent entendre ce que les Français ont
à nous dire et c'est pour cela que je
j'estime qu'il est trop tôt pour prendre
des décisions qui finalement ne
respecteraient pas la parole de chacun
et chacune cela ne nous empêche pas de
travailler d'anticiper effectivement des
procédures administratives et c'est tout
l'objet de ce texte donc nous allons
voir comment l'Assemblée nationale va
amender ce texte j'imagine dans un sens
qui tiendra mieux compte du débat public
bon on voit bien la volonté d'envoyer un
message politique sur le soutien aux
énergies nucléaires du Sénat vous savez
que le gouvernement soutient aussi les
énergies nucléaires mais ce qui est très
clair c'est que nous nous prendrons pas
les décisions avant que les français ait
eu le temps de s'exprimer d'abord le
débat public un mot très rapidement sur
le calendrier de l'autre texte sur
justement la part du nucléaire les
autres énergies dans notre mix
énergétique quand est-ce qu'il va être
annoncé et quand est-ce qu'aura lieu le
débat au Parlement alors moi mon
objectif c'était effectivement de faire
le maximum pour pouvoir avoir un texte
qui puisse être présenté avant l'été au
Conseil des ministres ensuite ce sera un
enjeu d'organisation du débat
parlementaire vous savez que nous avons
beaucoup de textes beaucoup de textes
d'ampleur je ne pense pas seulement aux
retraites mais à la loi de programmation
militaire par exemple à des lois sur le
volet régalien qui doivent également
être prises donc nous ferons le point
avec le ministre de relation avec le
Parlement et bien sûr la Conférence des
Présidents pour trouver le meilleur
plutôt à l'automne se débat sur la place
du nucléaire nous verrons mais ce n'est
pas que la place du nucléaire je veux le
redire aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de
sortir des énergies fossiles d'être le
premier pays qui sort des énergies
fossiles car c'est là notre combat
[Musique]